foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
may I ask
why you chose to tell your truth when
you live in an amazing world with the
attention of so many in what could
totally be gotten away with as a veneer
because I was struggling alone for so
long and I felt like I didn't have
anyone that was being open with it and I
felt like I was I was just by myself in
this and I felt like something had to be
severely wrong with me to be the only
person in this industry that felt this
way and so when I started having these
conversations in private and I started
realizing that everyone is actually
struggling and no one is as happy as
they seem I was like we have to talk
about this I think I'm so glad that you
did everybody struggles yeah so
I related on levels that um are
difficult to talk about and I want to
thank you because you're discussing
stuff right now that I want to make you
feel safe about because I've been there
thank you so when you were struggling
there was like attempts at escaping life
yes
tell me about that
I got to the point that I just things
caught up with me that I never had
acknowledged I never wanted to face I
feel like I was sort of putting on this
facade and living in this like role I
had been assigned for so long and it
just all caught up to me one day and
then one day turned into weeks and
months and honestly I feel like it was
at least a year that I was just always
in this sort of like suicidal ideation
mindset it felt very normal to me to
think about that at the end of every day
and then yeah that wasn't until I ended
up actually making an attempt and was
thankfully obviously unsuccessful but I
don't know it just all it just all
became too much and that's when I also
decided like okay clearly there's
something more for me to live for if I
wasn't successful and I want to do
something with that and I want to be
able to say I made the choice to live
and what am I going to do now what does
that mean and did this happen twice yeah
I don't I don't like to I guess admit
that it happened twice because the
second time I sort of still brush off as
like no that and that should just show
how like not serious it was to me
anymore it became so normal that sitting
on a balcony and debating jumping off
was just something that I kind of did
and that's why I'm like was that really
that big of a deal and now obviously
with a lot of reflection and writing
about it obviously yes but yeah no it so
yeah definitely twice at least me as
well yeah twice
I don't know if I really wanted to leave
the Earth
I was so desperate that I did not
nowhere else to turn right
just want to lick a way out even if it
was maybe temporary but obviously it
can't be there's no like way to describe
it I always used to say to my best
friend I just want a temporary death
like maybe it's not forever but right
now it's too much and I want out
currently how did you
find your way out back I asked because
I've had to ask myself these very same
questions definitely I still ask it I
think that my biggest thing though was
I started doing a lot of inner child
work I started healing the little girl
in me like very seriously and that was
something I sort of dove in head first I
was like this has to be what I start
with I have to start with the beginning
of where I feel like this pain is coming
from so I really just like took that
very seriously I went on a couple of
mental health Retreats I did therapy
every single day of the week I just I
just really committed to getting better
whatever better even means so I just I
don't know I started to love myself the
same way I try to love other people
okay
I love you I know that for sure
everything you just said that was a real
roller coaster of incredible
productiveness in seeking help in
self-awareness and giving Grace to
others realizing you're not giving it to
yourself and you get to be the real you
you have carved that path out for
yourself with bravery and courage and
strength and I applaud that because you
never have to be fake or anyone but you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
now I work here in this beautiful space
with Ross Matthews you know him you guys
have done drag race together do you mind
if we pull that sensitive funny bird
into the conversation
[Music]